Tristan and I are I don't even know if I
want to say Tristan and I
I am having another baby as Khloe
Kardashian's drama with her ex Tristan
Thompson plays out on Hulu's the
Kardashians Coco's seemingly unbothered
abroad getting cozy with 365 days star
mckelli morrone in Italy
I do
Chloe was on hand at Milan Fashion Week
to support her sister Kim's Dolce and
Gabbana collab over the weekend that's
where fans spotted her looking all loved
up with the Netflix star more than once
I just want to live my life and be happy
the two sat next to each other in the
front row at the show on Saturday that's
Khloe and while you can't see McKelly's
face we know that arm rocking and orange
silk shirt right there next to the good
American founder is the Italian actor
are you lost baby girl
and when the Show wrapped Chloe and
McKelly posted up backstage I mean the
way she's leaning into him his hand
placement on her hip with his face
turned towards her is it getting hot in
here or is it just me isn't that crazy
oh but that's not all Coco and McKelly
were also seen chatting at an after
party for the event their arms wrapped
around one another talking closely into
each other's ears now whether this is
the beginning stage of l-o-v-e or just
friendly fun we'll have to wait and see
it's exciting this all comes after the
season 2 premiere of the Kardashians
where Chloe got emotional opening up for
the first time about welcoming a second
child with her ex I was definitely very
angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled Coco revealed that she did an
embryo transfer to have a baby be a
surrogate just days before the news
broke that the NBA star had fathered
another child with another woman
claiming that Tristan knew he was having
a baby when he pushed her to move
forward with the surrogacy process it's
just so close I wouldn't want anyone to
think I did this after the fact why
would I want to have a baby with someone
who's having a baby with somebody else
because I'm not that much of a sociopath
I'm a lunatic but not like that
deranged of course Chloe and Tristan who
also share a four-year-old daughter true
split following the news of his latest
infidelity and welcomed their newborn
son in August a source recently told E.T
Chloe is doing well and trying to gauge
the dynamic of her relationship with
Tristan but that will come in time right
now her focus is her baby
foreign
thank you